Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Gisela Giardino
En la vida, cuando hay un momento crítico,
uno mira para adelante y mira para atrás.
Para adelante, ¿qué se me viene encima?
¿cómo lo voy a afrontar?
Y para atrás, ¿cómo viví hasta ahora?
Y ¿en qué forma me ayuda esto
a vivir mi futuro?
Mi momento crítico es ahora.
Hace pocos meses falleció mi marido,
compañero de 60 años de vida.
La verdad es que no pensé que la viudez
me fuera a resultar tan difícil.
Es cierto que las raíces de dos árboles
que han ido creciendo juntos tanto tiempo
entrelazándose, embrocándose...
pero la cosa no pasaba por ahí.
Creo que lo que pasó tiene otra metáfora.
Estábamos los dos sobre un trampolín.
Al quedarme yo sola
me quedé sin el impulso,
sin el envión, sin la vibración síncrona
que nos disparaba al mundo
de proyectos y de aventuras.
Miro para atrás y veo mi vida
muy larga y completa.
Miro para adelante
y veo la necesidad de ir cerrando,
abrochando, abotonando.
De esto les quiero hablar a Uds. hoy.
De la importancia de cerrar
y de distintas formas de ir haciéndolo.
Lo hago usando ejemplos de proyectos
que jalonaron mi vida.
Octubre de 1957.
Desde la azotea
de mi casa en Nueva York,
vi pasar una y otra vez
en el cielo a Sputnik.
Era el primer satélite artificial
que habían largado al espacio los rusos.
Daba la vuelta a la Tierra cada 90 minutos.
Yo acababa de llegar a Nueva York.
Flamante Licenciada en Física de la UBA,
para estudiar en la
Universidad de Columbia.
Quien sería mi marido,
yo no lo conocía todavía,
estaba trabajando a raja cincha justo
en ese momento desarrollando un maser
que es un amplificador cuántico
que iba a ir montado
en el primer satélite norteamericano.
Ese satélite se lanzó en enero,
pero ya los rusos habían ganado la carrera
al espacio tres meses antes con Sputnik.
Sputnik desencadenó
un verdadero vendaval en los EE.UU.
¿Qué pasaba con la ciencia en los EE.UU.
si los rusos tenían
la ventaja en el espacio?
Rápidamente se aprobaron
fondos en el Congreso
y se convocó a las mejores mentes del país
para que efecturaran una reforma radical
en la enseñanza de la ciencia.
La propuesta era mejorar
la educación en ciencia de los jóvenes
y así sacarle la ventaja a los rusos.
Fue un proyecto del país entero
que duró una decena de años.
Y es el momento que me tocó vivir
y que marcó mi carrera profesional.
La enseñanza tradicional
--y así es como aprendí yo--
presentaba a la ciencia
como una serie de leyes
--por ejemplo, las leyes de Newton--
que nos han sido entregadas como Dios
le entregó las Tablas de la Ley a Moisés.
La bandada de proyectos post-Sputnik
buscaba presentar la ciencia
como un proceso semejante
al que sigue un científico
que va investigando y descubriendo cosas.
La idea era que los alumnos emprendieran
pequeños proyectos científicos
formulando preguntas,
buscando explicaciones,
formulando hipótesis, confirmándolas o no.
Tengo un puñado de bicarbonato.
Le agrego un poco de vinagre
y salen burbujas.
¿Qué son las burbujas? ¿Puedo apresarlas?
¿Y si las apreso en un recipiente
y le acerco un fósforo encendido?
La llama, ¿se aviva, se apaga, queda igual?
¿Le puedo poner un nombre a ese gas?
Mi rol en el esfuerzo post-Sputnik
fue desarrollar programas y cursos para
docentes en donde se presentaba la ciencia
con actividades como las que
les acabo de describir.
Esto iba de la mano con programas
de investigación sobre las ideas
que los alumnos traían al aula
y cómo se podían trabajar
para ayudarles a aprender mejor.
Todo esto para mí ha quedado atrás.
Pero si me pregunto cómo se cerró,
esa etapa se cerró entrenando gente
y pasando la antorcha.
Porque los materiales, la filosofía,
los resultados de las investigaciones,
todo eso subsiste en el trabajo
profesional de colegas jóvenes.
Pasado un tiempo resultó claro
que la ola que se había desencadenado
con la reforma en la educación
en la ciencia se salía del aula
y llegaba a otras orillas.
A zoológicos, campamentos, museos.
A mí me tocó barrenar la ola
en California en los años 80
hasta un museo interactivo.
Un museo interactivo es un lugar
donde lo que se expone
no son objetos valiosos,
sino fenómenos que el visitante puede
explorar con actividades ya preparadas.
O sea que lo valioso son
los fenómenos que se exploran.
Ahora, museos interactivos de ciencia
hoy día existen a granel en el mundo entero,
pero en aquel momento
al comienzo de los 80
los estábamos inventando de cero.
En el museo desarrollamos
varias exposiciones
que viajaron por Norteamérica,
Europa y más allá.
Cada exposición era un proyecto
con todas las particularidades
de lo que es un proyecto.
Que empieza con una idea,
sigue con el desparramo de ideas,
algunas no llevan a nada, otras florecen,
otras se van por caminos impensados,
otras aparecen de causalidad.
El proyecto va creciendo,
avanzando, abriéndose.
Pero llega un momento en que
se acabó la plata, o se acabó el tiempo.
Esto no lo podemos costear,
lo abandonamos.
Esto cuesta demasiado,
hay que dejarlo de lado.
Y así vamos descartando y cerrando
hasta que llega el día del estreno
y la muestra se inaugura.
Cerrar este tipo de proyectos quiere decir
que se ha logrado un producto final
que se lanza al mundo.
Por ejemplo, se publica un libro,
se abre una exposición, nace un chico,
se da una charla TED. (Risas)
Al mirar el conjunto de mi vida,
me di cuenta de que
si rasco un poquito por acá
me aparece un proyecto.
Rasco un poco por acá
y aparece otro proyecto.
A lo mejor grande, a lo mejor chico.
Pero algo que se abrió,
floreció y se cerró.
Tengo esta idea, esta imagen
de mi vida como un árbol
--digamos un pino--
que del tronco va largando ramas,
ramitas, agujas...
y va creciendo.
Se abre, se cierra con la copa,
y queda una estructura armoniosa.
Pero el detalle de la estructura
es igual a la estructura misma.
O sea que el pino es un gran proyecto
que está hecho de un sinfín
de pequeños proyectos.
Ahora bien, con esta imagen de la vida
--un proyecto formado
en un sinfín de proyectos--
ese proyecto se empezó a abrir, así
como fue abriéndose, se tiene que cerrar.
Esto quiere decir que
en mi vida octogenaria
ya no es hora de ir abriendo
proyectos nuevos
sino de ir cerrando los que
todavía están abiertos.
Yo tengo entre manos
el cierre de vidas queridas.
Por ejemplo, mi padre lideró en los años 60
una expedición arqueológica argentina
a lo que fue el Antiguo Egipto.
Y trajo piezas que se exhiben
en una sala que montamos
en el Museo de Historia Natural
de la ciudad de La Plata.
Esa sala está abierta al público.
Pero para mí, falta un libro ilustrado
sobre la vida de mi padre
haciendo esta expedición
para poder terminar
mi parte de ese proyecto.
Entonces, ¿por qué
es tan importante cerrar?
Si los proyectos no se cierran,
las ideas se pierden.
Los cerramos para darles
la forma necesaria para que sobrevivan.
No para enterrarlos y olvidarlos.
Los egipcios mismos
momificaban y sepultaban
justamente para que el muerto
pudiera sobrevivir en el más allá.
Visto así, el cierre es liberador.
Volviendo a la imagen del pino,
el gran proyecto de proyectos,
con buena suerte lanza semillas
que caen en terreno fértil
y engendran un pinar.
Eso sería la inmortalidad.
A mí lo que realmente me importa
es mi vida, mi pino.
Que sea una estructura
armoniosa y coherente.
Poder decir, cierro mi vida
y mi vida me cierra.
Cerrar una vida y terminar con
una vida "que cierra" es mucho trabajo.
Pero es trabajo que vale la pena
porque da sentido al diario vivir.
(Aplausos)